parle pas là
mais qu'est-ce 4,6 à
ogeu rythme je n'ai jamais autant ri
[Musique]
je vais mourir de rire casimir tu
trouves pas que tu exagères tu ferais
mieux de venir nous aider vous aider
pour un un arbre de noël pareil mais je
ne veux pas être ridicule qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça casimir et pourquoi
serais-tu ridicule il est très beau
notre sapin de noël mois il est petit il
est tout petit le mien sera beaucoup
plus grand une partie du tout dit
regarde nos jolies boules dieu
bof
eh bien les miennes saurons plus grosses
plus jolie et plus brillantes et le
dialogue regarde ça elles sont belles
elles sont elles sont toutes mitterrand
on dirait des vers de terre
peut-être qu'avec ce que la crème
chantilly ça fera un dessert correct
mais alors sur un arbre de noël à
contenir tu crois pas que ça suffit
comme ça tu nous garde tout notre joie
de faire un des arbres de noël c'est
vrai et puis ont su ce que ton sapin
soit plus beau que le nôtre bataille
d'un arbre de noël nombre de guirlandes
et boules qui attend ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance le plus bel arbre de noël
c'est celui qu'on fait soi même regardez
chez vous vous êtes d'accord votre arbre
de noël c'est le plus beau
oui il y en a qui sont pas mal
mais vous verrez le mien à côté de celui
là avec vous vous guirlandes miteuse et
vous tout petit bout vous verrez le mien
sera tellement plus beau avec ses
splendides d'irlande elle ces
merveilleuses bull c'est ça c'est ça
casimir vas-y vas-y comme ça du nougat
sera plus les pieds jeu court chercher
toutes mes affaires vous savez quoi quel
culot il est super neutre a évidemment à
tiens vous êtes là excusez-moi kazimi on
a tellement agacé que j'avais même pas
remarqué que vous est-il françois
revient dépêche-toi et nous que notre
travail soit fini quand casimir viendra
j'arrive julie excusez-moi faut que j'y
aille
gelly puis à 37 12 y'en a pas logo
[Musique]
attrape l'ont attrapé la doré la de
l'argenté qu'il ya trop de dommages
c'est vrai bien repassée mois voilà je
ne vais pas ici et voilà
comme ça c'est cynique il est vraiment
beau notre art de noël n'est ce pas
j'aime période que quasi mieux va dire
en voyant ça
or on l'a là haut
alors ça y est c'est ça votre arbre de
noël
dillon si tu veux te moquer d'où tu
ferais mieux d'aller faire le tien on
verra quand tu es qatar mais j'y vais
j'y vais et avec tout ce que j'ai dans
ses cartons ce sera un arbre de noël
comme vous ne l'avez jamais vu c'est ça
c'est ça aulas vas-y vas-y kazemi bon on
me roy
questionné les hangars de
casimir on n'a jamais vu un arbre de
noël comme toi vous rendez compte je
suis tombé en plein dans mes cartons ici
les enfants soient partout regardez le
sapin bonjour
bonjour bonjour
bonjour à tous je suis le père noël à
père noël dans l'île aux enfants c'est
incroyable
qu'est celui là bonjour les enfants
tiens il y à un autre père noël
diaries serait ce le vrai père noël j'y
comprends plus rien de père noël
bonjour mes enfants
qu'est ce que ça veut dire il ya déjà de
père noël la situation se complique
ça devient de plus en plus embarrassant
nous sommes droit maintenant on va il ya
quelque chose d'anormal il faut que
j'aille voir ça
messieurs
écoutez moi
il ne peut y avoir qu'un seul père noël
alors il faut que ceux qui ne sont pas
des vrais père noël enlèvent leurs
costumes sinon on y reconnaîtra rien
c'est moi j'utilise c'est françois oui
je m'étais déguisé en père noël pour
faire une surprise à nos amis mais je
pensais qu'on serait trop bas il en
reste encore un qui fout je voulais moi
aussi distraire nos jeunes amis chère
julie je suis navré
va écouter c'est pas grave monsieur 19
mai alors
7 devrait ternir ce ne serait pas très
honnête de le laisser croire
la même idée comme les surgissent nord
et que françois les grands esprits se
rencontrent
résultat nous avons bien rater notre
coup aux poursuites mais c'était quand
même très sympathique
d'accord mais ce coup ci c'est peut-être
le vrai nous allons avoir l'air ridicule
chercherons
pas d'affolement pas d'affolement ils ne
sentent bien reconnaître sept vols
bonjour les enfants
je suis le père
[Musique]
dont casimir tu sais que c'est une très
bonne idée de naître déguisés en
casseurs
l'idée est excellente comme ça c'est
qu'il ya le déroutant à notre époque
c'est que n'importe qui a le droit
d'avoir de bonnes idées mais comment
avez vous reconnu
multitude comme sors tu sais on avait
dix ans - peut-être un petit rien dans
la démarche l'année marque bon enfin en
tout cas je vous ai apporté une belle
surprise
qu'est ce que c'est que ces milices
j'adore les surprises kwassa ginocchi
lever bien anne germain est venu avec
moi
internat mais c'est formidable c'est
elle qui chante la chanson de l'île aux
enfants oui et ce soir elle va là
chantées en entier
mais encore là venez avec nous venez
chanter la ville on est censé les
enfants avec anne vous êtes prêt à vous
en sentez vous allez chanter avec anna
[Musique]
et
ce jour n'est pas
[Musique]
très
machination
c ses chansons matinée
chambre
le printemps c'est le choix
[Musique]
si seulement aux parents havre pas
vivre dans notre hymne tout serait
j'attends la vie saine
[Musique]
ces deux pays
étrange
et
le son dans l'est
bien au chaud devant
journée s'achève vous pouvez déjà
détruit à revenir chaque nuit d'amour
[Musique]
c
à rien
[Musique]
ces pays
à
[Musique]